earliest a previously unknown variant at
the forty suspected chains catching many
experts back on the breaking news
leading with unconfirmed reports of a
small highly rehearsin re and National
Guard units converging on trains and
bridges are closed it's more talks as a
very real detonate this is not a panic
situation
smallpox is an acute contagious viral
disease that is estimated to have
resulted in 300 to 500 million deaths
throughout history the initial symptoms
include fever and vomiting the xin
followed by the formation of sores in
the mouth in a skin rash over a number
of days the skin rash turns into fluid
filled bumps with a dent in the center
the bumps then scab over and fall off
leaving scars the disease is spread
between people or via contaminated
objects the risk of death after
contracting the disease is about 30%
with higher rates among babies often
those who survive have extensive
scarring of their skin and some elect
blind the earliest evidence of the
disease dates back to the 3rd century BC
and Egyptian mummies in 18th century
Europe it's estimated their 400,000
deaths per year were because of the
disease and as recently as 1967 15
million cases were reported in a single
year following this the World Health
Organization intensified its efforts to
eliminate the disease the last naturally
occurring case was diagnosed in October
1977 and the World Health Organization
certified the global eradication of the
disease in 1980 one of the last cases of
smallpox occurred in Birmingham United
Kingdom in 1978 a medical photographer
contracted the disease at the University
of Birmingham Medical School and died on
the 11th of September 1978 all known
stocks of the smallpox were subsequently
destroyed or transferred to two World
Health Organization designated
laboratories the United States Center
for Disease Control and Prevention and
the Russia's state research center of
virology and biotechnology the World
Health Organization first recommended
destruction of the virus in 1986 let us
keep getting postponed due to resistance
from the US and Russia in 2002 the World
Health Assembly agreed to permit the
temporary retention of the virus stocks
for specific research purposes
in the division we're introduced to the
virus well after it's taken hold of New
York City and is spread to other parts
of the world it shows all of the usual
characteristics of smallpox except for a
couple of quite major differences
firstly administer spread among the
population long before any symptoms
started to show and secondly the
mortality rate was considerably higher
the smallpox virus was nothing like the
virus we've seen through history it was
some new variation some sort of new
super bug but where did it come from and
why now and this is where I introduce
you to the man behind it all dr. Gordon
Amherst Amherst was a calm collected man
but he had a reputation as being a
controversial and dangerous individual
even before the outbreak of the dollar
flu he would practically cause riots at
lectures he would hold and was otherwise
considered an unpopular figure by
virologists like dr. Jessica Kendall
Gordon Amherst is the man behind the
creation and outbreak of the dollar flu
as reasoning for creating and spreading
the green poison was that humanity was
too powerful on a global scale and
mother nature needed help in advancing
her creations mankind is the greatest
threat to the survival of the planet
through their own greed but he had the
cure Amherst also had a Darwinist point
of view only the strong deserved to live
and his creation as the tool to ensure
that this happens but at the same time
he is willing and accepted that his
death may come from his own creation
Gordon Amherst was friends with vitaliy
to tinker and worked with him in Russian
labs through this friendship he had
access to genetic libraries of many
different pathogens as well as Vitelli
research notes he was able to modify the
basic smallpox virus by combining it
with several other dangerous diseases
like Ebola and h1n1 on top of the see
also modified the genetic traits that
controlled the incubation period and
made it so that it could even spread
while it's incubating in the host this
made it particularly lethal because by
the time that the host was showing
symptoms it had already spread to a
significant number of others using a
protein printer Amherst was able to
create the final form of this virus just
in time for Black Friday one of the
United States busiest retail days of the
year his plan was to spread this new
virus via means that were most in
contact with people during the shopping
holiday money hints the name the dollar
flew
before it was realized that it was
smallpox people took the epidemic for
just a particularly bad version of the
annual flu also because medical
personnel got sick too
the medical infrastructure quickly
collapsed even once smallpox was
discovered to be the base strain of the
virus the modifications made to it had
known vaccinations rendered useless when
it came to the treatment of the sick the
people capable of researching and
developing a cure were likely also
infected making it difficult for an
organized effort to be made the lack of
quarantine treatment and the changes
made to the virus ultimately led to the
dollar flu being as widespread and
lethal as Amherst hadn't ended up to be
the main target that Amherst had in mind
for the beginning of the end of mankind
was New York department store ables
being that it was Black Friday
Able's were filled with eager shoppers
ready to take advantage of the specials
eco recordings show Amherst among the
shoppers handing over contaminated bills
to the cashiers these were the first
victims of the dollar flu from here the
bills transferred to multiple shoppers
with in Manhattan and within hours the
airport and in the rest of the world it
was from this point that we lose track
of dr. Gordon Amherst he just vanished
perhaps he was sitting back watching the
chaos unfold the second wave division
agents number one priority was to find
em hearse before any more damage could
be done and have him explained what he
did and how to stop the disease
eventually em whose fate is found only a
short time into the outbreak Amherst
succumbs to his own creation his body is
found in an apartment building only a
few hundred yards from the outpost on
the Hudson River with a second wave of
agents first arrive in Manhattan however
the agents weren't the first ones to
find him Aaron Tina was one step ahead
and along with M hosts research notes
protein printer and fatality Nikko's as
hostage he disappeared
fun fact Gordon and hostname does have
some sort of historical relevance
Jeffery Amherst was a British Field
Marshal and a commander-in-chief during
the 1700s and governor of the English
and French territories that would later
become Canada there are a number of
achievements that he's recognized for
but there's one in particular that links
him to the doctor Amherst that we know
in the division in 1763 there was a
rebellion were a number of Native
American tribes joined together and lead
an assault on the British during this
time there was an outbreak of smallpox
in the fort and it was Amherst that came
up with a suggestion of using the
outbreak against the c-team tribes he
actioned this by having smallpox
infected blankets fall into the hands of
the native tribes in 1780 Amherst was in
charge of the British Army that was
involved with suppressing riots in
London because of the way the situation
panned out Amherst was forced to resign
as commander in chief this particular
situation is known through history as
the Gordon riots ok so hopefully you've
enjoyed that and maybe learnt a thing or
two I'll be back next week with a video
on well I haven't actually completely
decided yet if you have any suggestions
let me know in the comments Cheers
what you're looking at is the smallpox
virus one of the deadliest pathogens on
the planet for centuries it did a
wonderful job of helping keep the human
population in check
[Music]
but times change
and sometimes mother nature needs a hand
in improving her creations like say
speeding them up a little bit making
them contagious when they should be
quietly incubating in a host or making
them more lethal
[Music]
I didn't come up with the approach on my
own my friend Vitali is one of the
pioneers in the field and the idea has
been around for years genome has data
you see once we digitize DNA we made it
infinitely beautiful we could do a
thousand virtual variations in the time
it used to take to grow a one lab grade
generation of pathogens and we could
pick the best most lethal combinations
and make them real that's how you make a
killer virus you see mix in genetic code
from other diseases and you move the
sliders all the way up on lethality and
virulence the goal was a 90% mortality
rate I'm not sure my green poison is
gonna quite hit that but honestly that's
just details as long as most of humanity
goes the earth stands a fighting chance
technically technology is what's killing
the planet but that's not really the
case it's the greed that drives the
technology but a funny thing happened on
the way 200 dollar genome maps and 3d
printed plastic toys someone figured out
those technologies could be repurposed
modified for the greater good
me
now my virus is gonna do what nature's
always done decide who lives and who
dies and if nature decides I die then I
die
there's nothing else I'll have a lot of
company natural selection at its finest
helped along by a little unnatural
genetic manipulation it's all data
really life's just a method of
processing the same way I processed the
smallpox genome on my laptop and who's
to say that wasn't the plan all along if
by some miracle you survived green
poison then nature's decided you deserve
to live the rest of us shouldn't and
won't Godspeed
I'll see you in hell
[Music]